touchdown
hayden hurst meanwhile he's going to
wind up hitting him first here
for a touchdown
dear hayden get ready this is going to
be a wild 10 years
no one could have imagined the twists
turns ups and downs the crash
and the resurrection like your beloved
phoenix
life will be radiant and shining then
suddenly you'll burst into flames
and nearly die only to be reborn from
the ashes to become a first-round nfl
pick
[Applause]
shortly after your 14th birthday the
accolades will come
throwing in the upper 80s as a pitcher
the local sports anchor will do a tv
segment on you
but during that throwing session you'll
feel a pop and your velocity will begin
to lag
a month later dr andrews the top
orthopedic surgeon in the country
performs tommy john's surgery on you 12
months after the surgery you're on the
mound again
and then the roller coaster takes off
kennedy fires a pass complete
in high school you'll play both football
and baseball and by your senior year
you'll be one of the top pitchers in the
country you're projected to be a late
first or early second round pick in the
mlb draft
but when the time comes you'll wait two
days to hear your name called
it will damage your ego
the pittsburgh pirates will grab you in
the 17th round
and off you'll go as a 19 year old for
your first
year in minor league baseball hard
throwing
right-hander hayden hurst but tighten up
life will spiral
downward from here you'll develop the
yips
ruining your ability to throw with
accuracy
you'll tumble into depression and spend
thousands of dollars on therapy
but it will all fail you
you'll turn to alcohol and drugs to kill
the pain
you'll be in a precipitous free fall and
that will bring on more drugs and
nightly drinking until you black out
finally in 2015 at the age of 21
you'll leave during spring training and
retire from baseball
the baseball dream will be dead
[Music]
but there will be another road you'll
walk onto the university of south
carolina football team in the summer of
2015.
you'll have some success but the demons
of depression will still have a hold on
you
and the drugs and drinking will only
escalate after a drunken night on the
town
you'll see no escape from the darkness
and in a chaotic moment
you'll make the calamitous decision to
take your own life
while sitting in your truck one night
you'll take out a knife and cut your
wrist
but god will watch over you
and despite being almost blacked out
drunk you'll miraculously call a friend
who happens to be in nursing school
she rushes over to stop the bleeding and
calls 9-1-1
the phoenix has exploded into flames and
is now in ashes
you'll be taken to a local hospital and
stabilized then moved to a psychiatric
ward and placed on a 72-hour suicide
hold
you'll feel alone embarrassed and like
you've let everyone down
you'll make a decision right there that
you will never be in this position again
you'll tell yourself the rebirth starts
now
you decide there will be no more
drinking and no more drugs
five years later you'll have kept your
promise and be completely clean
[Music]
south carolina football will have you in
therapy for several months and you'll
make a commitment to be the best
football player that you can be
and you'll blossom into one of the top
players in the country and on april 26
2018 the crowning moment of your
comeback you'll be selected by the
baltimore ravens in the nfl draft
along the way you'll learn to lean on
friends family doctors and therapists
you'll realize that despite what you may
think you are not alone in this fight
and you'll channel your hurt sadness and
anxiety into opportunities for others
going through the same struggles
you'll start a charity and raise
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
programs that address mental health
issues
and suicide prevention in teens and
adolescents
it's going to be an unimaginable 10
years
there will be colossal highs and then a
protracted seemingly
endless journey through a personal hell
followed by an unthinkable event
it's a long tough mental fight
be ready because everyone knows
in the end the phoenix rises gloriously
from the ashes
thank you hayden hurst you saved a lot
of lives today someone is listening to
that
right now and is saying he's telling my
story
i so admire his his courage his bravery
and his candor to share that
but the most important message that i
think he says is to let people know you
are not alone
and it really does get better even when
it doesn't seem like there's no way out
and that's such an interesting thing
that's such an important point
and i've heard so many people who've
been through this say the same thing
and and want to share with other people
that you're not alone because that's the
way you feel in that moment
the capacity for transformation that we
have as human beings
is always astonishing yes yeah
men be vulnerable yes yeah yeah be
vulnerable make time for vulnerability
and reflection it's okay
it's okay we thank you kyra cleveland
who's a knockout producer here great job
adam a t
you too and lee hooper who shot it
nicely done
it takes a lot to put a piece together
like that very very very nice
if you or someone you know is
experiencing a mental health crisis
you can call the national suicide
prevention line it's 1-800-273-8255
or maybe it's easier to text hello to
741
741
you